[Music]
hunger Clause at your grumbling belly it
tugs at your intestines which begin to
arrive aching to be fed being hungry
generates a powerful often unpleasant
physical sensation that's almost
impossible to ignore
after you've reacted by gorging on your
morning pancakes you start to experience
an opposing force fullness but how does
your body actually know when you're full
the sensation of fullness is set in
motion as food moves from your mouth
down your esophagus once it hits your
stomach it gradually fills the space
that causes the surrounding muscular
wall to stretch expanding slowly like a
balloon a multitude of nerves wrapped
intricately around the stomach wall
sense the stretching they communicate
with the vagus nerve up to the brainstem
and hypothalamus the main parts of the
brain that control food intake but
that's just one input your brain uses to
sense fullness after all if you fill
your stomach with water you won't feel
full for long your brain also takes into
account chemical messengers in the form
of hormones produced by endocrine cells
throughout your digestive system these
respond to the presence of specific
nutrients in your gut and bloodstream
which gradually increase as you digest
your food as the hormones seep out
they're swept up by the blood and
eventually reach the hypothalamus in the
brain over 20 gastrointestinal hormones
are involved in moderating our appetites
one example is cholecystokinin which is
produced in response to food by cells in
the upper small bowel when it reaches
the hypothalamus it causes a reduction
in the feeling of reward you get when
you eat food when that occurs the sense
of being satiated starts to sink in and
you stop eating
cholecystokinin also slows down the
movement of food from the stomach into
the intestines that makes your stomach
stretch more over a period of time
allowing your body to register that
you're filling up this seems to be why
when you eat slowly
you actually feel fuller compared to
when you consume your food at lightning
speed when you eat quickly your body
doesn't have time to recognize the state
it's in once nutrients and
gastrointestinal hormones are present in
the blood they trigger the pancreas to
release insulin insulin stimulates the
body's fat cells to make another hormone
called leptin leptin reacts with
receptors on neuron populations in the
hypothalamus the hypothalamus has two
sets of neurons important for our
feeling of hunger
one set produces the sensation of hunger
by making and releasing certain proteins
the other set inhibits hunger through
its own set of compounds leptin inhibits
the hypothalamus and neurons that drive
food intake and stimulates the neurons
that suppress it by this point your body
has reached peak fullness through the
constant exchange of information between
hormones the vagus nerve the brainstem
and the different portions of
hypothalamus your brain gets the signal
that you've eaten enough researchers
have discovered that some foods produce
more long-lasting fullness than others
for instance boiled potatoes are ranked
as some of the most hunger satisfying
foods while croissants are particularly
unsatisfying in general foods with more
protein fiber and water tend to keep
hunger at bay for longer
but feeling full won't last forever
after a few hours your gut and brain
begin their conversation again
your empty stomach produces other
hormones such as ghrelin that increase
the activity of the hunger causing nerve
cells in the hypothalamus eventually the
growling beast of hunger is reawakened
luckily there's a dependable antidote
for that this video is made possible by
our community on patreon and if you're
curious about health and nutrition check
out this playlist
[Music]